hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today we're doing an ask guy Jake that's
ask I just eat for short so I asked you
guys on Twitter for some questions and
most of the questions we're about the
new iPhone we are nearing September
falsely I am counting down the days I
feel like every one of those advent
calendars like the countdown to
Christmas but this is like the countdown
to my Christmas and that's iPhone
announced in a day so it's officially
happening on September 12th which I'm
extremely excited about if you can't
tell it I'm not slurring my speech
I'm slobbering all over myself I'm a
freaking mess let's get into the first
type of question that I have these are
not all gonna be - questions just the
first few so stay tuned Monisha wants to
know if it would be better to get the
iPhone 7s or the iPhone 8 there's in so
many different rumors there's gonna be
an iPhone 7s there's gonna be iPhone 7s
plus there's a naveen iPhone 8 which may
be called the iPhone in addition or
there might be an iPhone Pro we don't
know here's the thing the iPhone or
whatever that version of the new phone
is going to be they'll probably be one
of the most expensive phones to date
basically an all-over upgraded phone and
v7s is going to be a slight upgrade over
the 7 whereas the iPhone 8 will have the
new vertical camera will have the larger
storage OLED screen potentially USB see
charging instead of the Lightning and I
answer your question what did you even
ask me oh I feel like for a lot of
people looks gonna depend on the price
point how much do you want to spend on
this phone so basically that's what I
asked you how much is too much to spend
for the new iPhone Frank the take is
asking black or white iPhone
I mean it's looking like most of the
rumors are the black the white and the
copper color I'm probably gonna do the
white version I've been super into the
black and I don't know oh gosh I'm not
sure I don't think I'm gonna get the
copper I'll probably get it just to make
a video of it but something the drive
doesn't be kind of crazy and I've said
that so many times before is that I
always have a case on my phone because I
am app hazard I am so unable to hold a
phone in my hands without dropping it
and so I hate being able to see the
color of my phone unless the case
matches it perfectly granted this is
black and white but that's sort of a
theme that I'm going for and again I
might go for the black phone because the
camera is black which would then show
the white here and then if I do
a minute to get back to you because I'm
having a lot of internal conflict right
now and I'd rather not have that on
camera what features are you looking
forward to most in the next phone so
there's gonna be a lot of cool things
that I'm super excited to check out I've
also been using iOS 11 for a few months
now and I absolutely love it so usually
when you get your new phone loved the
biggest shocking things is the iOS is
completely different so for me that's
not going to be that different but it
will be exciting to see how they
integrate iOS 11 without the touch ID oh
boy
I'm wondering if people are going to
like that or if they're not gonna like
it I'm used to it only because I've been
using my Samsung phone and the pixel
phone previously we'll see how the
iPhone users kind of adapt to not having
the touch ID button it's something that
we've all been so used to having for so
long well that's about it for the iPhone
questions Kristine is asking what's the
last thing that I watched on Netflix and
I have watched so much Netflix in the
past month usually in the summer things
kind of tend to slow down in the whole
YouTube and entertainment world a lot of
people are traveling a lot of people are
on vacation and doing this or that so I
decided I'm gonna watch Netflix and I'm
gonna focus and I'm gonna watch it much
met flicks as possible while still sort
of maintaining some sort of social life
and my youtube channel I watched all of
that Oh Jay Simpson show that was on FX
or was at Showtime or something all of
it in like two days so good and after
that I watched three seasons of American
crime and then I watched Ozar and then I
watched more chela and there's a few
other things that I watched in between
that but most recently this past week I
watched daredevil oh I watched defenders
that's why I started watching daredevil
because I had seen Luke Cage and watch
iron fist and a lot of people didn't
like iron fist but I really really
really liked iron fist
leave me some comments below if anybody
else like that show too cuz I really
enjoy it and also I don't want to make
any of the comic people mad I have never
read a comic in my life so I'm just
gonna be completely honest with you I
don't know the differences between the
comics and the shows and the comics and
the movies I love superhero movies I'm a
huge fan of Marvel so I've been really
enjoying everything that Marvel has been
putting out on Netflix
more specifically love the defenders
that was the last thing that I watched
and then I was like shoot I never
finished daredevil so I finished all of
Daredevils
yesterday I just started on season 2
today and from that I'm excited because
they also announced that the Punisher is
gonna be out this fall which yes sign me
up I'll be there I will be bending that
day one of the release anyway what was I
talking about
describe your dog in one word perfect he
is a perfect Prince when am I gonna
upload some stuff on my gaming channel I
don't think I'll ever upload anything on
my gaming channel anymore this is my
main channel if I'm going to be posting
any gameplay it'll probably be here
running several channels by myself it
was not fun I didn't enjoy it it was so
stressful I was always worried about oh
my gosh I have to post two or three
gaming videos a day which would then
take away from my main channel which was
my main channel and my main focus then
basically everything suffered my video
suffered you suffered I was suffering
because I was putting myself through
this abusive cycle of shadows more
videos got those four videos you got a
post more videos and I was like hold on
a second my gaming channel basically
ruined gaming for me because it wasn't
fun anymore it was for a few years and
that just became like a chore so since
I've stopped my gaming channel I have
enjoyed playing games again I can just
sit crappy posture snack drink my
coffees in my garamantes feet up
enjoying my game to myself and not have
to entertain or talk to anyone that's
the way gaming should be so many
products of people who could do live
streams like I just man can't I don't
want to entertain I just want to sit for
me gaming has always been an outlet sort
of take me out of whatever world that
I'm currently in and put me into another
one to take my mind off of things so
yeah that was a long story short or was
it a short story long hmm next question
sorry my camera died I'm better he wants
to know who I'm gonna Mane in destiny
and at the time of making this destiny
is not out yet it will be out today I'm
shooting this on Tuesday so tonight is
the night
and my plan is to probably mean as a
hunter that's what I played on the first
one so we'll see I'm not sure I haven't
really decided yet but you can bet when
I do post it which I probably already
have posted it on Twitter or Instagram
story you can check it out there for an
update I'm so excited for destiny me and
my sister plan on playing a lot we
played so much destiny one when it first
came out and then it sort of fell off
for us so I'm hoping that this is one of
those games that I still enjoy playing
for a long time so I'm thinking that my
plan for gaming the next few months is
gonna be play destiny until Mario comes
out and then I'm gonna play Mario until
Call of Duty comes out and then I'll
play Call of Duty for a little while and
if I haven't finished Mario I'll go back
and play that and then kind of
intermixed destiny Mario and Call of
Duty within whatever timeframe I have
what I like about Call of Duty is just
playing simple multiplayer matches like
there's no thoughts I don't have to
think I just kind of turn on the game
and I'm just like investing equally it's
gonna be a long-term commitment
whereas Mario I'm just gonna play until
completion and then that's that did I
answer your question I don't wants to
know what my favorite false snack is
pumpkin bread I love pumpkin bread so
much I love pumpkin bread in the morning
in the night in the evening in the day
and the whenever as a snack it's for
dinner for lunch whatever man pumpkin
bread is so good Oh Jordan let's know if
I play PC games and I guess I sort of do
I mean I definitely don't play as much
as I used to I've played Minecraft on
the PC and the last piece of game that I
had played it was overwatch which I
chose to play on PC because most of my
friends playing overwatch played on PC
and how I decide usually when I play
games is where are my friends at so if
my friends are playing a game on xbox
I'm gonna play there if they're playing
on PlayStation I'll play there I'm
playing on PC I'll play there as well I
think that's pretty much yeah I think
that's it actually those are all of our
questions that we have for today thank
you so much for watching if you guys
have any questions you can feel free to
leave those in the comments below and I
will answer them by typing back to you
like a rule something I was gonna say
analog that's not analog it's still
digital doesn't say it's really basic
but it's not that basic I don't know I'm
not sure I had a lot of caffeine today
so I'm gonna get o and drink some water
to calm down from all the caffeine and
the excitement that games are coming out
time to flight oh I'll see you later I
love the holiday season
I don't know
[Music]
you